[Music]
uh I actually was commissioned to write
a book called black Jean Lies some years
ago and this was at the um wishes of Dr
Pastor Klo Dollar in Atlanta Georgia the
World Changers Church and um I have done
a lot of work in the Atlanta Georgia
area for many many years starting in
1991 uh when uh Andrew Young who is one
of the captains of the Civil Rights
Movement with Dr King and uh uh Andrew
Young uh was scheduled in 1991 to have
both his knees replaced he was scheduled
for double knee replacement surgery and
his son Bo called me and said hey can
you help my dad I hear you're working
with athletes and joint problems yes so
I make a long story short went to
Atlanta set up a nutritional program
with the mighty 90 for Andy young the
past ambassador of the United Nations
for for the United States US
representative from Georgia and mayor of
Atlanta very well-connected political
guy and he canceled his double knee
replacement surgery I rebuilt his knees
in 60 days and we've been good friends
ever since he's been using the mighty 90
every day since then uh he just walked
five miles he swims 5 miles a day and at
83 years old he's he's a great guy I can
knock on his door at any time of the day
or night and we'll talk we just are
great friends and he introduced me to to
um Pastor dollar whose 11-year-old
daughter had terrible asthma who's not
responding to medical treatment and uh
using the 90 essential nutrients and
changing your diet a little bit we're
were able to solve her problem she's 11
years old not responding very well to
medical treatment and we're able to turn
it around and eliminate eliminate her
asthma completely just in two weeks time
well I also worked on Evander
Holyfield's heart after he had his near
fatal heart attack guess what here's a
guy came came back a year later passed
all the physicals for the boxing
commissions and it's because of the
mighty 90 I want you think about this
Theo Ratliff great NBA player his career
was over 10 years ago I mean his career
was over
and of course we rebuilt him in 90 days
he's been using our products ever since
of course he's had I don't know probably
a hundred million doar worth of
contracts ever since so we're very very
excited about all the contribution we've
given to modern times for the black
community now the beat goes on uh six
months before her death I spent time
with with um Dr King's wife credtis
Scott King spent two hours alone with
her and she told me Dr King's wishes for
the future and what we could do to
further the health of the black
community uh and I'll just sort of
regress here just a second and leave
that for a moment and it was one of the
best two hours I've ever spent in my
life to speak with somebody and actually
listened almost for the two hours as
Spellbound as credit got King pter heart
out to me and told me what Dr King was
going to do after he finished up and put
the last um cross in the te's and Dot in
the eyes on the Civil Rights Movement he
was moving on to the medical system
which was a great disparity between the
black community and white Community
anyway in this last census that came out
in 2010 it's very clear that the average
black men in America Liv be 62 the
average white man in America lived to be
75.6 and the average um uh Hispanic man
lived to be 80.6 18.6 years longer than
than the black man not genetic it's
simply that the Hispanics still use
Grandma's home remedies and the black
community overuses overuses the medical
system because they they've been taught
incorrectly and fraudulently that all
the diseases that afflict the black
community and greater percentages in the
white Community are because of some
terrible black Gene well Pastor dollar
wanted me to write a book called black
Jee lies which I did you can see in the
acknowledgements we acknowledged Pastor
doll and his church for funding the
project and um this book goes into all
the diseases that are thought to be
genetic in the black community and the
the medical doctors use the black
community as an ATM machine
and they they just tell lie after lie
after lie to the black community there's
no law requiring medical doctors to cure
you when there's a cure available
there's no law requiring a doctor to
prevent a disease in you when there is a
prevention available and this is the
basic root of the problem this is why Dr
King was moving into the uh healthc care
field after he finished up with the
Civil Rights Movement his life was cut
short but uh credit Scott King his widow
has told me before her passing we spent
two hours together and she told me that
that was Dr King's wish that we solve
the medical problem she says uh Andrew
Young and Theo Ratliff Vander Holyfield
have told me that you are a person who's
been working very well with the black
community and solving problems such as
diabetes and high blood pressure and
heart disease and getting people off a
heart transplant list and getting people
off of dialysis and getting people off
the kidney transplant list and so on I
said yes ma'am she's okay then guess
what you're responsible you got to go
out there and tell the story because
obviously Dr King isn't here so we have
to have somebody with some health
knowledge to do this and I guess you're
the one and so I've been doing this
since
1991 in the black community and I again
this book Black Jee lies there is a CD
by the same title it's actually black
Jean Lies 2 is the one you want to get
it's actually a condensed version of the
book Black Jee lies goes into all the
diseases that are thought to be genetic
in the black community and tells you how
to prevent them how how to reverse them
using supplement programs well don't
forget if you want to know who Jim Crow
was if you want to know who coined the
term black Jean or black is beautiful
who coined the term black is
beautiful who who was Jim Crow If you
get a hold of that book Black Jean Lies
and I I have actually won dinners from
University his black historians because
they didn't know